[موسيقى]
في خضم التوتر المستمر تخرج المعارك عن
جبهاتها المعتاده وتتحرك نحو الجنوب في
خرسون وعبر نهر دنيبر في عمليه وصفها
الجيش الاوكراني بالخاصه والنوعيه وهي
عمليه انزال عسكري على الضفه الجنوبيه
للنهر الذي يشكل حاجزا طبيعيا بين قوات
البلدين يقول الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته
نفذت عمليه خاصه في معقل القوات الروسيه
بالمنطقه ودمرت مركز للقياده الروسيه هناك
ما اسفر عن مقتل عدد كبير من الجنود الروس
في المقابل اعلنت القوات المواليه لروسيا
في خرسون انها افشلت هذا الانزال بينما
اشار الجيش الروسي الى استهداف مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب جسر اندونيسكي بعد
حصوله على ما قال انها معلومات استطلاعيه
في الجنوب ايضا قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
الاسطول الروسي يشهد حاله اضطراب بعد
الاستهدافات الاخيره وان موسكو تنشر 10
سفن في البحر الاسود لكن ليس بينها حاملات
الصواريخ محذرا مع ذلك من ان خطر الهجوم
الصاروخي الروسي ما زال مرتفعا وعوده الى
الجبهات الشرقيه قال الجيش الروسي من جهته
انه احبط محاولات هجوميه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في دنياسك واكد ان الطيران
الحربي نفذ ضربات على اهداف اوكرانيه في
خمسه اتجاهات ابرزها
من جهه اخرى تتوالى مشاهد قصف مواقع بها
مدنيون اخرها اصابه طفل جراء القصف
الاوكراني على دير القديس جورنال في
مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه المحاديه للحدود مع
اوكرانيا حسب مشاهد نشرتها وكاله تااس
الروسيه وياتي ذلك في وقت تحتدم فيه
الاتهامات بين الطرفين فاستهداف المدنيين
[موسيقى]